ben i i i want to get to the movie but
first i have to ask you about the hair
it looked amazing okay two rules
i'm never gonna let you win
and i'm gonna always tell you the truth
your father is dead
i'll take care of you teach the male
sciences the key to the great
performance is a great hairdresser and
you have a great hairdresser you can do
anything um that i'm increasingly
relying on my hair for the performance
as i as i get older and you know what
why not just lean into the you know the
quad no the it it's great actually
because like when you do a period movie
that
this period is not that long ago but it
is a recognizably different time you
know those details like the the way the
hair looks and the clothes and the
saturation they do so much of this work
for you that creating this world and it
um it really makes a difference when
it's done well you know your grandfather
is a selfish old prick who resents
taking care of his family and yet you
all end up back here at my house welcome
your only uncle i'm also your favorite
right sounds like something maybe
you two have great chemistry what was it
like working together how did you build
that chemistry how did you get going
especially in the middle of kobe
the kobe was the was was uh hard
yeah it makes it a lot less fun right
yeah we had like all these face masks
and stuff on it was like hard
to like interact with each other it was
annoying it wasn't annoying but we had
like the face shield that was protecting
our face you couldn't see anything then
we had the mask
couldn't even breathe we had to get in
our circus tool takes mummies we
you know the truth is like you're right
that's a good point about chemistry it's
very much like somebody playing
basically you're a kid or or your best
friend or you're you're you know a
parent or a wife or something it's like
if you're playing somebody who who
you're supposed to have known for years
and years
like you kind of can't fake that
connection you just have to get lucky
and find it and work with people that
you actually really do love and and and
find
you know great to be around and it was a
pleasure i was so happy
when i met daniel and and so he was
doing this what kind of guy he was and
what kind of life he had and whose
parents were uh i just knew he was going
to be fabulous and and and no surprise
because george
is so smart about and cares so much
about actors and acting and casting his
movies he does it so well um and but i
think both of us really got lucky with
dave one more thing very important never
hit a woman
even if she stabs you as scissors
got it how was it working with ben and
george
it was great i love them so much like my
real family members i gotta say
it was they were just so nice to me and
i loved them like ben was like my real
uncle and
george was like my
dad on set and it was just great
and i just love them so much
okay these are two pretty big names to
work with but what was it like just
hanging with them what is the cool thing
you learned about ben
uh
this guy had big names he's like listen
if you're not on youtube you know what i
mean you know
it's like my kids that's all it's like
youtubers that's like if i played
minecraft on youtube i'd be impressive
to my son but you know unfortunately
you're saying you're like oh
oh let's play minecraft dad
it's true
ben in a movie like this where you're
you're forming chemistry with someone
who is going through a tough time you
have to channel at some point your kids
and you have to think about how this
stuff would affect your kids because
that's what immediately i kept thinking
about wow these are the things i never
want to do and these are the things that
i want to do is that going through
yeah i mean that is the central kind of
meaningful aspect of this story to me is
the extent to which
how important it is to be present in the
life of your kids and and if you play a
role in another child's life how how
much of an impact you can have that your
family doesn't have to look like
any particular
model you what it needs is like love
adults that care about you and that give
you a sense that you're worth something
you mean something and you can do it and
you see conceding succeed and you can
get through difficult things if you can
internalize those lessons i think you
have a much better chance at being a
happy healthy adult george is so good
because he's an actor connecting with
actors but um would you want to do a
movie with him again and act with him i
would love to uh and in fact if i was
acting with him
i would want to get his notes as a
direct because he's so smart about
acting he really understands acting for
the camera
about the importance of not just like
there's a sense i think you have
sometimes that actors if they feel the
emotions authentically and you feel
connected to the part that that's that
you're doing the job and george has
another level of understanding and
complexity and nuance that he brings to
it which is a real understanding of also
what choices you make as an actor maybe
the scene's funny and you thought it was
sad maybe it's maybe or maybe you get
angry at a certain you know like he he
knows how to really
both surprise the audience and also in
doing that make it all of a sudden more
relatable and authentic it's a he's
extremely sharp i actually was like
george do you want to come with me how
much does you charge to um be an acting
coach you know what i mean i can't pay
the uh you know those those kind of
rates those are big premiums
big numbers you know what i mean last
daniel real quick
would you do would you let these guys be
in another of your movies
uh yeah i was my whole career is on this
answer
you think about it what would you make
me audition you'd think about it you'd
hire me right yeah
you wouldn't even have to audition
audition no in life
you gotta have it
if you don't have it
you never get it
and i say you got it